republican glenn younkin defeats
democrat terry mcauliffe in high stakes
virginia governor election this is an
insider story
uh in virginia's gubernatorial election
he won uh tuesday's race was the biggest
test of president joe biden and his
party strength since democrats won back
in the white house in november 2022 and
the senate in january ranking a wealthy
uh former private equity executive and a
co-ceo of the carlisle group as a
political newcomer and funded much of
his own campaign on the campaign trail
young depicted himself as an economic
conservative and largely avoided
discussing former president trump who
lost virginia by double digits in 2020
trump spokesperson liz harrington shared
a statement on twitter saying that trump
and young can get along very well
together and strongly believe in many of
the same policies at the same time the
biggest story believe it or not wasn't
the governor was a lieutenant governor
marine
veteran winsome sears becomes first
female and woman of color elected as
virginia's lieutenant governor cbs news
republican winston sears was elected as
virginia's new lieutenant governor on
tuesday now becoming the first woman of
uh female of uh first woman of color to
serve in that position i'm at last four
awards for the first time in my life cyr
said an address to supporters on
election night what you are looking at
is the american dream the american dream
this is the not the first barrier series
as broken sears or u.s marine veteran
previously served in virginia's house of
delegates she was the first black
republican woman first female veteran
and first legal immigrant
woman i think she's from haiti she's
from jamaica a woman elected to that
position she says on her campaign
website when my father came to this
country august 11 1963 he came at the
height of the civil rights movement from
jamaica and he only came with a dollar
75 she said on the victory speech when i
joined the marine corps i was still a
jamaican but this country had done so
much for me i was willing
willing to die for this country how big
of a deal is this the fact that
republicans won virginia time i'm going
to you first i think it's a huge huge
deal that has implications going into
the midterm
and the democrats are in disarray um and
i'm going to curse starting with the
sleeping [ __ ] you know everybody from
the top down
is freaking out about what's going on um
this morning i was reading james
carville came up and said we need to go
to the woke detox center because the
defund police lunacy and take lincoln
names off schools is being noticed by
mainstream americans and voters and they
don't like it on the other side the far
left where five percent are
catman
you know omar said we need to double
down because this race baiting that
defeated us by the way she said that
this race baiting that defeated us wait
a minute she's got that flipped over
and then tim kaine
uh democrat ohio he said let me tell you
folks we better get our act together
because this is the ghost of christmas
future wasn't tim king a vp candidate
yes he was six years ago wasn't he from
virginia at the time
and then now he's democrat ohio well you
know once upon a time hillary was in
arkansas then she was in new york yeah
and jfk jr was alive well but look at
that you've got moderation from tim
kaine reasonable statement carville
freaking out saying hey all the stuff
that we did would defund the police and
i'll take lincoln of school is it bad
and then omar saying no no no we need to
double down it's like there's three
parties in a democrat party and they're
all freaked out but i'm so
really really proud to see a person
um
that came over and she's lieutenant
governor now her speech her story i
think
to me that's the biggest story of the
election if someone comes from somewhere
and they can adam what do you think your
thoughts i think you're missing the uh
the biggest story is that this
non-politician came in there
and he actually ran as a traditional
economic conservative republican he did
not embrace trump at all and actually he
said i'm here for virginia let's keep
this election about virginia trump i
don't need you on this one buddy and
that's the playbook if you want to win
the general election if you're a
republican if you want to win your state
and saying hey trump i respect you thank
for all you've done i'm good because it
because it's all about converting yes if
you're going to embrace trump and run to
the mega crowd sure you're going to get
that but you're not going to win a state
like virginia biden won virginia by i
think double digit points
a year ago one year ago and now terry
mcauliffe who was a the governor of
virginia what 10 years ago running again
lost to yunkan the playbook here is that
you don't need trump to win you're going
to get moderates like myself or people
that could go either way and say you
know what the best ideas are with this
guy junkin this guy um
terry mcauliffe shot himself in the foot
because he made a lot of comments about
parents and school and uh you know
critical race and and stuff like that
and people said i'm sick of that and you
have to j people like james carville
and um
[Music]
tim kaine but that wasn't the worst
thing he said
he told parents
that they have nobody's what he said
he made some bad comments correct like
that that clearly shot himself with the
foot the the the bottom line is what i'm
saying is this guy won fair and square
he didn't need to
cozy up to trump in order to win that's
going to be the playbook for other
moderate republicans moving forward is
that look
fight your fight you don't need trump
there for you backing you up you can win
without trump and i hope to see that
happen hold on hold on hold on hold on
virginia's a blue state
you think the republicans won
you don't think democrats flipped that's
his point that's literally that's
literally what i just said republican
moderate republicans that you don't need
trump with moderate republicans you
didn't tell me you didn't say that
democrat are the ones that flipped
because that's what ended up happening
here i'm saying independents and
moderate democrats flipped yes yeah so
exactly
so i think what he's saying is if he had
embraced trump those that flipped may
not have because precisely no i don't i
don't but i don't agree with that
why is that tell us why i don't agree
with it because people are tired of the
walk left
trump or no trump people are tired of it
they're tired they're done of you
telling them how to live their life
trump or no trump i think virginia was
going to flip yeah but
i think the republican strategist over
here i think does have a valid point
because look at california look at we're
sick of the walk mentality too but we
didn't get rid of gavin newsom i think
this is a win for common sense
california is a whole different demon
all right okay you can't compare it to
virginia okay let's talk about virginia
for a second i think this is a win for
sanity i think this is a win for common
sense if you have hope because he
flipped this thing in the last month or
two i mean he was way behind in the
polls and when this idiot mcauliffe went
out there and started talking about crt
you know telling the parents they have
no choice that was it the suburban mom
says you're done all right and that's
how i think it's going to be in other
parts of the country as well
disagree i disagree and this is why i i
would hope that they're going to flip
because a lot of people have been
talking to me about that too that this
is going to be a purple state and it's
all new jersey and i'm going to tell you
why i'm going to tell you why i don't
think that it is because
there are some strategists and i talked
to a couple of them and they're like
our policies worked
they
jack citarelli only lost in new jersey
even though they called it even though
the votes aren't fully tallied yet
maybe 2 000 votes
he's had 10 000 people phil murphy alone
in the last four years has had
a hundred thousand people that would
have voted against him leave the state
so what they're saying is is now there's
four years where they can
widen that gap let's get more of these
independents out let's get let's
strengthen our base and let's get these
small business owners out let's get
these older people out let's use our
policies and what elon omar is saying
you know she's a dog whistle and she's
using coded language but what she's
saying is is that we need to primary
these moderates justice democrats that
far left they do not go after the right
they don't run in blue count in in
in purple areas and they don't run in
red areas they find blue strongholds and
they run far to the left of the
incumbent it's what they did with new
york and aoc aoc didn't uns she wasn't
some young whipper snapper that unseated
a republican she wasn't some young
whiffer snapper that came in and shook
something up she took a district that
was democrat for 70 years and made it
socialist
they they run to the left of the left
that's what elon omar is doing and
that's what they're looking in michigan
right now where they're literally
burning documents they're actually
burning documents in michigan right now
because
you didn't see that no i i must have
missed it
but that works in districts that doesn't
work on a national or state level
nonsense it definitely works in the
state level and then it works politics
start local and they branch and they
branch regional if you make it in
untenable for a voting base to stay they
leave they come to florida they leave
they go to north carolina so this 2000
remember there's over a million over one
million more registered democrats in new
jersey than republicans there's more
registered democrats in new jersey than
there are registered any other political
affiliation combined outside of
independence and they and he won by 2
000 votes after 100 000 people left in
the next four years if he does the
mandates again if he shuts businesses
down again another hundred thousand are
gone by the end of next year it actually
it actually strengthens his power
to hurt his state i mean so that's
that's something you got to be very very
aware of the the actual politics the
political machinations behind this you'd
like to see it but what i do hope on a
federal level with the midterms coming
up is people look at what joe manchin
did he held the line he didn't allow
himself to get bullied kristen sigma
didn't allow himself to get bullied they
tried to force this in before these
elections now joe manchin holds the keys
to the democratic party you got people
that are coming up in these purple areas
in these purple districts and they're
looking at joe manchin saying man he's
got a point joe manchin could run this
party if he really wants to joe manchin
is the guy that says all right now you
guys come to me i think he realizes that
he does it i really do it's the shadow
speaker of the house the third point i
have on this is that man i love how much
immigrants love this freaking country
man and this is something the republican
party screwed up with for 40 freaking
years with their hard line against
immigration you look at what winston
sears is you look what pat is you look
at what people are man and they come to
this country and they're willing to
fight for this country i would love like
israel has the birthright where you want
to go to israel we should have a
birthright you want to be a communist
you get two years in any economy in this
country that you want we'll buy you the
ticket there you buy the ticket back all
right you want to be a commie birthright
birthright here you go 2 000 american
tax dollars enjoy venezuela for two
years come on back and let's have a
conversation that was pitbull's message
at his concert about a month ago you see
that no yeah pitbull talking to the
crowd the ufc fighter with the long hair
too uh
the same thing yeah so so let me go back
to the question here because this this
is the part i'm curious what you guys
because he took it there and we went a
little bit but we didn't fully go there
so trump three days ago said this guy's
gonna make a great governor he flat out
said it so that is a form of an
endorsement then they had a call
yesterday after winning and and of
course he's playing the card of listen
this is about virginia this is not about
trump i'm just trying to do this to win
this i'm here for the state
does trump's endorsement mean today what
it meant three years ago yes do you
think it still means you're stronger i
think you're stronger i don't i don't
say no i'm gonna say stronger i'm gonna
say no we're tired of it i i'm seriously
i mean i wasn't you know i was in favor
of what he did as president but i'm not
signing up for another four years of
that i think there's a better
alternative no no there's not there's
not but but
what we're failing to understand is that
when
pat pat said something very true uh a
while back he says when you go too far
left it creates a far right when you go
too far right it creates a far left
right because so what happened is that
right now bro there's people still with
trump flags
people there's there's boat rallies he
just had one yes his words still carried
away maybe not with you but i'll tell
you one thing and i don't care i'll say
that it carries great with me because if
you endorse somebody i'm like hey bro
you were in the office you dealt with
these guys more than i did if you're
thinking that's direction that's a
direction by the way i don't agree with
everything because he created the
vaccine i'm not i'm not antibiotic but
let me let me tell you something you
as as sincere and as heartfelt as you
are you might be literally the most
irrelevant voter in america what do you
mean you're
a republican in california you carry
zero weight you can't even win your
state
the fact that you love trump is
irrelevant trump california ain't going
to trump no you can't you can't get
gavin newsom out of my office and
everyone hates him
your opinion is great in
glendale or wherever you live
bakersfield
it's it's irrelevant the fact that you
love trump you need someone like tom to
say
i'm back on the trump train baby you
need someone like me saying you know
what this guy [ __ ] poopy pants biden
i can't do it again right trump ain't
gonna do it homie and that's why i'm
saying your opinion is irrelevant i
think you're wrong i just think you're
wrong
how do you have boat rallies i have 300
dollars worth of [ __ ] quarters
ricky
you're wrong
and i need 700 pesos more buddy you just
did a rally did you hear the deal that
we did by the way you didn't hear about
the deal
you've seen that ricky's pointing his
car for sale yeah and he's been riding
around on horses okay so he you know
he's complaining about gas prices and
inflation and i said ricky i'm gonna do
you a favor you know the shipping crisis
and supply crisis supply chain i did i
said ricky i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
take your car off your hand it's fine i
got you i'll pay the shipping fees i'll
pay the gas three bucks here in florida
thank you i'll pay for the shipping you
just ride your horse around in
bakersfield we'll be okay and i'll spot
you the 700 extra dollars so you don't
have to worry about it so we'll call
ourselves even but i just so i'll just
send bricks just send the new mercedes
over here to facebook let me just say
this one point i i think trump is a
release for people that are so fed up
with some of the crap that's going on so
he goes and does a rally where he knows
he's going to be embraced and he still
is a brand but i think the times call
for a very serious politician of course
and somebody that really really has the
best entrance of the country at the
heart and is smart and strategic and has
a proven track record and it's probably
leaning towards those
so tom has been indoctrinated into the
common sense hold on hold on so so the
highest stock market in uh american
history lowest unemployment amount right
now the current highest stock market in
american history because it's a place
today inflation without inflation the
highest stock market in american history
the lowest unemployment in american
history energy independent lower
tensions with russia and in north korea
that's not a track record look i i'm
just saying but there's but there's the
other side of that which divides the
country and someone else can do what he
does
in a different style and way other
presidents haven't done it
well to me this is what it comes down to
i look at facts 44 other presidents
haven't done it let me let me let me
you're the most irrelevant voter in
america
congratulations it's not about being
irrelevant it reminds me of the factions
back in the day with like jerry falwell
and stuff like that where you'd have to
go get the evangelical faction right the
the
desantis voter let's say right every
single trump guy they can they can you
know yell scream every single trump guy
would vote for december 100
there are people who voted for biden who
would vote for desantis there's not a
single not a one single biden voter who
would vote for trump yeah no no i so
do you understand what he just said
though that's i get but you're not
understanding what i'm telling you i'm
not a trump guy
okay sure no but i'm not i i like what
he did because i look at the fact i
think it was necessary as well
he was necessary bro i don't there's
he's not my savior i hustled i was
slaying
weed when george bush was president
allegedly allegedly when i was 13 like i
don't need a man to fix my life but what
i'm saying is to say that he didn't do a
good job with this country is completely
ignorant
that he did only did a bad job would be
naive but to say he only did a good job
would be nice i'm not telling you that
there's like there's a gray area there
i'm not telling you that's not the case
but in 44 presidents haven't been able
to do what he did that's what do you
have 44 presents
in america in history
you're basically saying trump is the
best president ever for what he has
another president been able to do that
i'm talking about specific topics i'm
not talking about
he's the best human being in the world
lowest unemployment in american history
has never been done no not lowest in
history the lowest in 50 years no
if and if you look at it especially with
the hispanic the black uh communities it
was the lowest in history so what i'm
telling you is this when you look at the
facts and you compare if i have to go
between biden or trump but now if
there's a descendant in the mix of
course the santa is going to be the bet
because he's going to win over people
more but right now we're not we're not
there we're so extreme on both sides
pray that you're the republican parties
nominate someone like the sanctions
by the way the status or you will run
away
nobody wants a republican or a democrat
they can't even gain five percent of the
vote but i didn't hear what you just if
the rock ran what did you do i said how
useless is my libertarian party that in
an era where literally nobody wants to
vote republican or democrat they can't
even count because they don't have a
marketable candidate that's that's all
they don't have a market well you guys
have run joe jorgensen gary johnson over
the last uh i like gary johnson but yeah
you like gary johnson i did like gary
johnson so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you